well some breaking news now the
government has just released
the regular latest test and trace
figures showing an increase of more than
40 percent in positive
test cases for covid in just one week
well let's go live now
to our technology correspondent roland
manthor roland tell us more
hi adam yes a big jump
in the number of positive cases
registered for the week between
27th of august and 2nd of september so
not quite up to date but for that week
almost 10 000 new people tested positive
and the statistics which as you can
imagine they're always very dry
they call that a notable increase and it
really is isn't it 43
jump and i think this just echoes what
we heard yesterday from
chris whitty patrick valance and boris
johnson cases arising
we also got numbers for the success
of test and trace and i have to say i
think these are
also concerning test and trace is now
consistently
reaching 70 percent of contacts
identified
in other words it is missing three in
ten people
and it is stabilized at that level we've
got cases going up
the big question is as the prime
minister said yesterday
can we deal with this can we contain
these cases before they turn into deaths
and hospitalizations
test and trace performance suggests that
it might not be
the tool that we really need and just on
the 70
success in tracing contacts identified
that's the point isn't it because quite
a lot of contacts are still not being
identified
yes exactly so so test and trace gets
through to about
80 percent of people who test positive
and then gets through to about into in
total of 70
of all the contacts and yeah you have to
that's that's always the thing that you
have to wonder so after all the people
who test positive
only 80 to contact it what happens to
the 2 in 10
who test positive and just simply
disappear
this is this has been a problem for the
system since the very beginning
and the thing is is that until now it
hasn't mattered
so much because cases have been confined
to clusters
you know from a practical point of view
obviously it's totally awful if you have
a hundred cases in a meatpacking plant
but those 100 cases that you can
identify
quite easily you know where they all are
now as we understand
cases are once again rising in the
community and that makes them much
harder to identify
and so yeah this this difficulty
it's hard to see how it's going to
improve and for all of us it's hard to
see how it's going to contain the virus
in the way that we want